In the last video, we saw
how blood sugar concentration
or glucose concentration in
your blood of 80 milligrams
per deciliter was kind of a
normal fasting blood glucose
if you hadn't eaten for
eight hours or before a meal.
And the fancy word we learned in
the last video was preprandial.
What I want to do in this
video, because 80 milligrams
per deciliter really doesn't
make a lot of tangible sense
to me, I don't know
exactly how much
sugar that is, what
I want to do is
try to put this in
the different units
so that we can
better conceptualize
how much sugar that
might be in our body.
So let's just do a little bit
of unit analysis over here.
So if we have 80
milligrams per deciliter,
that's what we're talking about.
That's a normal fasting
blood glucose level.
Now let's think about how
much that is per liter.
A deciliter is 1/10
of a liter, so if we
want to cancel out the
units, we want deciliters,
we have deciliters
in the denominator
here, so we want another
deciliter in the numerator.
So we want to know
deciliters per liter,
because then that and
that will cancel out.
And there are 10
deciliters per liter.
And so that gives us 80
times 10 is 800 milligrams
per deciliters cancel
out, milligrams per liter.
Now, if we want that in terms
of grams, we can just multiply,
we want to get rid
of this milligram,
so we want that in
the denominator.
Milligrams, we want
grams per milligram.
1 gram is 1,000 milligrams.
So once again,
milligrams cancel out,
and then you have
800 divided by 1,000.
So 800/1,000 is 0.8
grams per liter.
Let me start over here.
So we have 0.8 grams per liter,
and then to make sense relative
to a normal human body, I
looked this up on the internet,
the average human body,
and so I'm assuming,
I'm like 5'9", 150 pounds.
I think I'm pretty
close to average.
But they say the average human
body has about five liters
of blood.
So let's multiply this times 5
liters per human, per average
human, obviously, a small
human will have less,
and a very large
person will have
more blood flowing through them.
But this is an average
person right over here.
So then we get the liters cancel
out, and so we get 0.8 times 5.
8 times 5 is 40,
0.8 times 5, going
to have one decimal
place, it's to be 4.
0.8 times 5 is 4, and then
we have grams per human.
4 grams per human.
And just to get an idea
of what four grams are,
1 teaspoon is
equal to 4.2 grams.
So 4 grams is almost
a teaspoon, so it's
approximately 1 teaspoon
of glucose per human being.
So in your entire
bloodstream, you
have about a teaspoon
of sugar that your cells
can use to do whatever
cells need to do.